[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of people reacting to what Joe
burrow had to say about concussions
yesterday and uh he was on Colin
cowherd's podcast and said this about
the position you play and you sign up
for
part of what we signed up for you know
you're going to have head injuries
you're going to tear your ACL you're
going to break your arm that's the game
that we play It's the life that we live
and we get paid handsomely for it and so
I'm I think going into every game and
you know we we know what we're getting
ourselves into all right he also had
this to say about concussions he
suffered like I said I've had some where
you know I don't remember the second
half or I don't remember the entire game
or I know that I got a little dizzy at
one point but nothing nothing lasts long
lasting
all right people reacted like oh my god
well this is what you sign up for
sometimes you don't want to hear the
answer
you know it's like hey look at that
steak
do you want to know how you got that
steak on your plate no no no no no not
at all
surgeries oh successful surgery yeah
I'll tell you how I did it
he asked a direct question and he got a
direct answer from Joe burrow you know I
did that with Troy Aikman did that with
Drew Brees did that with Kurt Warner
we're shocked when they're honest
because a lot of times they have to be
dishonest you know Drew Brees said he
would even tell his wife if he had a
concussion
he told us that the other day that he
would lie so if you're 24 years of age
like Tua is he going to go to the
sidelines and go hey I got a concussion
I need to come out
he's going to go I think it's my back
Dan orlovsky said that look if I was
playing I'm 24 I'm lying
Chris Sims joining us now I mean you
busted your spleen you probably still
tried to hide that when you played
didn't you I did that's I mean you're
saying it right Dan I mean a hundred
percent it's it's a performance business
and then you know you put yourself in
the two of shoes so what you're talking
about first off football players want to
play football quarterbacks are usually
and generally love the game in all
aspects of it right they're got a little
Mojo it's the first time in his NFL
career he's got some positive stuff
going on with him he knows he's got a
pretty good backup Teddy Bridgewater
behind him he doesn't want to give him
that chance so yeah you know again I've
said the Florio a million times when we
had this conversation if I was in
today's NFL I got my head hit hard I'd
I'd get up doing something with my
shoulder and yeah there was no way I was
bleeding internally and dying out and
bleeding out they weren't taking me out
of the game I didn't know I was that I
thought maybe you broke you know a rib
and it was touching my lung or whatever
but it is is the nature of the Beast I
think Joe burrow hit this you know
perfectly I at no point thought Ray
Lewis running into me at full speed was
good for my body when I signed up for
football I wasn't like you know I think
I'll live longer if Rey runs into me
full speed and just cleans my clock a
few times so it's a big boy sport it's a
sport of big people and of course it's a
lot of intensity and people fighting for
their careers and that leads to some
violent you know hits on the football
field okay how do you have your spleen
get what was the medical term that did
it explode and who hit you well it was
it was actually it was Thomas Davis
right and Chris Jenkins it was kind of a
double whammy we had a play called 23z
in and I thought I was going to have the
crow route open and somebody flashed in
front of it and now I [ __ ] the ball back
because the pocket was collapsing I was
gonna throw the ball out of bounds and I
saw Thomas Davis coming at me but as I
was throwing the ball and gotten that
compromised position Chris Jenkins hit
me from behind and it really like
extended me right almost into a back
extension and that at that moment is
where Thomas Davis put his the crown of
his helmet right in the the soft spot of
my belly and yeah you're not thinking
you're you know bleeding internally I
thought maybe I broke a rib I didn't
know what was going on but I was
extremely uncomfortable and I kept
telling the medical staff I could play
and thank God after the game the doctor
was like hey let's just go to the
emergency room because it might be your
spleen and thank God he did that because
I don't think I had a a whole lot longer
to figure that one out
all right uh assess this game tonight
what's wrong with these two two let's
start with these two quarterbacks what's
wrong with Russell Wilson right now uh
all right I mean obviously not
comfortable in the offense quite yet and
you know and honestly I gotta say a
little bit I gotta put some on Russell
here all together I did a long breakdown
of this on my Chris Sims unbuttoned
podcast a little yesterday where you
know there's just there's some plays
there to be had right now Russell Wilson
is not seeing the field real well he's a
little unwilling to pull the trigger and
play football within the pocket the
right way for the quarterback position
you know when I watch them over the
first four weeks I go Dan if if it's not
a one-on-one shot or if the first reads
not wide open then it's I don't know
what's gonna happen he's gonna look
around and look at the rush and lose
sight of things downfield and throw a
check down or end up having to throw it
away so he's certainly not playing very
very good football and and you know
they're running the ball okay the system
itself I know that system it's rooted in
McVay I mean uh Gruden and Shanahan and
McVeigh and all that so I really know
the reads and understanding but can it
be fixed in Denver I I do think it can
be I do I I they gotta just you know
he's gotta trust the offense trust
what's what he's seeing a little bit
more and there is potential there the
o-line like we said it is pretty good
and Judy Sutton and then KJ Handler
there are dangerous that way so there's
meat left on the bone and yeah I'm not
giving up on their offense there's
enough answers within the scheme
Russell's got to play better and and you
know trust the offense a little bit more
all right what's wrong with Matt Ryan
there's a few things here now
you know
one is you know lack of lack of things
to be scared of on the offensive side of
the ball I think that's the first thing
they got no Sutton Judy you know Michael
Pittman Jr is a very good receiver but
not the kind of guy you go whoa we gotta
reorganize our defensive game plan and
double him or we're going to be in
trouble because it's going to be bombs
away over our head they have no element
of that that scares you in the past game
let alone I think you couple that with
Matt Ryan's inability to scare you with
his ability to push the ball down the
field and now we're talking about an
older quarterback yes who is getting
horrible pass protection and can't run
the football you know that's one there
where I don't know if it's fixable as in
the Denver I say there's still potential
this one is scary I mean the fact that
it's the worst scoring offense in
football they get you know sacked a lot
they make a lot of mistakes and
turnovers there's nothing good right now
both of these offenses are reeling but
I'm a little more concerned with the
Colts and a.m Broncos all right how far
into the season do you make an
assessment this is who this team is
let's say give me another few weeks I
think you know end of October yeah about
the end of October maybe even
mid-october where you get through five
you know you get to we're getting close
there to six six games where I'd go uh
this this is really them this is how
they're gonna play this is this is an
issue this year it's not like oh it's a
one or two game blip it's I've been
saying this forward to five weeks and
you know that's where I'm a little
concerned with the Colts because it's
really been almost every week and you
know the one game they won was the
Chiefs where you know they had three
three four five Shamrocks up there but
to pull that one out and had every break
in the world to get that Victory he's
Chris Sims pro football talk live
co-host and contributes to NBC's
football night in America and a former
NFL quarterback
watching the Rams lack of offense
offensive line no running game Cooper
cups on Pace for 190 catches I mean if
if you're Odell Beckham Jr
of all of the teams here that you can go
to when you're healthy right what who is
number one on that list that you would
say that's where you want to go I I mean
it's not the Rams right now I know all
the other things are the Rams right hey
they got his locker he loves them they
love him he loves living in La all of
that but you know I think to the point
you're asking here and the question is
just like if he wants to set himself up
for a Payday and you know a big contract
for 2023 or 2024 and and so on I don't
know if the Rams are there you know a
little bit like we talked about the
Colts there I got real questions and the
Rams like you said the offensive line
it's not the same they lost people there
you know the running game is a
non-existent and then a little like we
were talking with the Colts offense too
there's no element that scares you you
know Cooper Cup's really good but he's
not the kind of guy that scares you 70
yards down the field he's the guy that
scares you 5 10 15 yards downfield build
with the occasional tactical down the
field shot so they don't have anybody to
open up the offense and right now you
know McVeigh can't find that one thing
that kind of stresses the defense out
right to then play off of that and and
compromise you you know in the years
past with like Jared Goff right it was
the speed sweep in the outside Zone and
he kept you out of balance and had a
whack with that and he could develop a
bunch of plays off of that last year
play action pass and a little running
the ball opened up everything they
nobody ran more play action passing
through the ball down the fields more
than they did but that opened up all the
Cooper cup and easy underneath stuff and
made it all look great right now there's
none of that lack of pass protection and
offensive line play like I'm concerned
with the Rams I mean they're they're no
way Super Bowl caliber they are low
level barely getting in the playoffs uh
in the NFC type of team to me right now
best team in California is who oh I I am
I just want to make sure it's the 49ers
okay no I I don't you know I don't care
that the 49ers are two and two the 49ers
are one of the best teams in football
and as long as Jimmy G doesn't do things
that we saw in Denver a few weeks ago
they're gonna win the majority of their
games and even last week I mean again it
wasn't great on Monday night we can I
can go back to the first half and show
you a handful of plays and go damn can
the guy be any more open can can can he
just serving it up for you the wide open
receivers and the game should be you
should be up by 14 or 17 instead it's
17-9 late in the third quarter like how
the hell does that happen so but I do
think that they'll figure it out with
him and of course it's early for him
here too and I think the 49ers their
roster is as good as anybody in the
league it's right up there with the
Eagles and the Dolphins and the Bucks as
far as most talented teams in in the
league why does it feel like Jerry Jones
is trying to push Dak Prescott to get
back sooner
and in the meantime talk about how great
Cooper Rush is
right so I'm trying to understand his
logic of you you love this quarterback
man we're surprised and he's playing
great but he keeps giving us updates on
Dak and hoping he'll come back against
the Rams yeah I do think he you know put
a little unwanted or unneeded pressure
on the situation at first and and again
they're gonna need Dak Prescott you know
this is one of my pet peeves of the week
there's two things on social media is
Jared God better than Matthew Stafford
like what like get the hell out of here
okay like that that thing started are we
kidding me come on now we've lost our
mind we're going to be such prisoners in
the moment and what I want to tell
everybody is Detroit's offense has more
Talent than the Rams really so that's
the other thing and and there's a lot of
reasons for that but come on and then
the other thing here is is Cooper rush
and the Dak Prescott quarterback
controversy like come on now let's get
out of town in here first off the thing
I want to say is Dan Dan if Dak Prescott
played the way they are playing the last
few weeks and put up the stat line that
Cooper Rush is putting up we'd all be
going is something wrong with Dak in the
offense what's going on but now they've
won the game because we didn't expect it
and it's ooh maybe there's a controversy
and then that's where you know I think
Jerry Jones didn't help the situation
out but hey they're they're playing
great on defense they're playing balance
football they got a few tricks every
game to help Cooper Russian company out
where I always that's a pet peeve of
mine to go where are those tricks when
the starter's in there or when the
starter's in there let's not just go
well he's better so let's throw it 45
times a game and lose balance they seem
to fall into that trap the Cooper Rush
has played well but don't rush it back
with Dak press got to your point they
the Cowboys are better than I expected
they're a real player in the NFC the big
picture is more important here and
Cooper Rush it's been good but I was at
the Giants game in person there was
plenty of completions there to be had
that game shouldn't have been that close
you know last week he threw two bad
interceptions interceptions against
Washington that got called back that had
nothing to do with the play he just got
lucky that they got called they'll need
Dak to make the big time DAC plays as we
get uh going on here and and it's a
great job by Cooper rush but I don't
understand why Jerry did that either Dan
great to talk to you as always Chris
thanks buddy uh one of the guys I said
hello we uh we were on a topic to start
the show strange names that maybe you
went to high school with or college with
did you have somebody like bend over
April Showers did you man I feel like I
did it I'm choking uh oh eat we had uh I
grew up I eat a Fooda eat a Fooda uh uh
yes that was that was a real thing um so
that one I haven't pulled that one out
of my brain in a long time there but
yeah that was growing up that was
definitely one of the ones that stuck
out well because I you know Paulie said
no offense and I said wait is there
somebody named Noah fence there's got to
be right there's one person
yeah one person in the world named Noah
fence and then there's quite a few
gymnasiums
okay yeah okay a lot of a lot of Bend
overs
that's which is crazy how does that even
happen you think a parent would stumble
on that and just go that doesn't sound
right let me move on to another name
yeah yeah yeah but I like it deep
thoughts by Dan yeah
absolutely uh thank you buddy have a
good weekend all right YouTube that's
Chris Sims pro football talk eat a food
is that Italian
that is crazy because Noah Fant is so
close to no offense no offense